Mr President Madame Minister honorable
members in any fight it is always the
side fighting for something that has a
higher power on its
side it is the one who believes in what
they are fighting for that will
sacrifice and do what it takes to
Prevail and conversely it is the site
who fights against something that will
always be scared scared to lose scared
to think of the future scared to speak
out two years ago Putin and Russia
started a war against something a war
against Ukraine and its territory but
also against the people and a nation
with an Iron Will and hope for the
future against their European
aspirations against the values they
share with us and quite simply against
both modern reality and the strong tides
of European
history and in doing so Putin started a
fight against all of us against Freedom
self-determination and Democratic de
democracy at large against everything
that we have stood for over 70 years
Ukraine has proven the power of a Nation
and the people fighting for something
for themselves first and foremost but
also for us and for everything that we
believe in Freedom democracy rights and
aspirations some were surprised by
Ukraine's heroic action but no one
should have been surprised that when
faced with oppression subjugation and
tyranny they chose
resistance and that is why honorable
members I remain just as convinced of
one simple fact today then I was two
years ago standing in front of you and
that is that Ukraine will prevail and
that Europe will stand with Ukraine
every step of the
way honorable members we have spoken in
great detail over the last two years on
the eu's historic and massive support
for Ukraine be it military Financial or
human be it on sanctions security or the
single Market be it on the historic path
of Ukraine to our Union that this house
has been such a strong supporter
of but today on this poignant
anniversary debate it is a time to look
deeper at how we have got there and
where we must go the starting point is
that Ukraine and Europe have shown that
we are willing to fight and pay the
ultimate price for the things that we
believe in and this was one of Putin's
greatest miscalculations in that month
of February as he amassed troops on the
border and planned a quick lightning
strike on
ke Mr Putin you made this mistake
because you cannot understand what
drives a human Spirit when it is free to
think Dream create and prosper nor can
you understand because you cannot bear
to accept that a human desire for
Freedom will always win and honorable
members Putin cannot understand that if
you give people a choice they choose
Liberty once and for
all
and in Ukraine's case they fight for
Liberation he cannot understand that the
fight of the Ukrainian is different to
the fight of a Russian soldier whose
lives Putin has callously churned for a
past long gone and a future that could
never
exist Ukraine's sacrifice is the
opposite why do they fight because they
are battling toiling for something
existential and inherent to The Human
Condition this is why Ukraine's will is
not just stronger than Russia's it is
fundamentally different in nature and in
character and this is what Putin will
never comprehend about us this is why
his invasion was not just morally but
also strategically wrong he cannot
understand freedom and and why we fight
for it because his only instinct is to
crush what he
fears and this explain what has happened
in the last two years instead of
toppling ke dividing the European Union
and weaking NATO the exact opposite has
happened on each and every
count with the support of the European
Union and our allies Ukraine has not
only held firm against a bigger country
a bigger Army and a bigger
economy but it has retaken more than
half of the territory that Russia
occupied from the start of this
conflict they have knocked back Russian
offensives last winter and are doing the
same
now and this indomitable spirit is what
we have to keep in mind here in Europe
and right across the Democratic world at
this juncture of the war there's no time
for wavering there's no time for Naval
gazing the message Europe sent at last
week's European Council was crystal
clear and let me repeat it here Europe
will be at Ukraine's side for every
single day of this war and for every
single day
thereafter honorable members we must
keep up our momentum to support Ukraine
and to protect our own
future that means thinking about
reconstruction about security
commitments about strengthening the
International System to avoid any
repeats or
reruns it also means continuing to
support Ukraine in every way we can take
Military
Support so far we have trained over
40,000 Ukrainian soldiers our Union and
member states have mobilized 28 billion
EUR worth of military
equipment the European Defense industry
has increased its production capacity
for ammunition by
40% we will have delivered over half a
million rounds of artillery shells by
next month more than 1 million by the
end of the year but this is certainly
not
enough not only must we accelerate the
delivery of ammunition to Ukraine
as we look to the future we must think
of Ukraine's defense capabilities as
part of our defense capabilities we must
think of Ukraine's defense industry as
part of our own defense industry and
this is why we have involved Ukraine in
the
preparations of our own defense
industrial strategy it is a first step
which should lead to integrating Ukraine
in some of our defense programs with the
agreement of the European Parliament and
Council where
necessary this would not only help us
cater for Ukraine's defense needs it
will also encourage convergence and
Joint planning between our militaries
and defense
Industries Ukraine is a future member of
our European Union so it must get much
closer to us also in the field of
defense and this leads me to my third
and last point on Ukraine's path towards
our
Union the contrast with just 10 years
ago couldn't be
starer back then a pro-russia regime in
Ukraine was passing authoritarian laws
and killing protesters on the
streets
today this country has just given itself
new legislation to expand National
minority rights to improve the judicial
system and to ensure checks and balances
on
Power and this is what led us to
launching the accession
negotiations and this progress is
happening not only because Europe is
asking for it this is the Deep desire of
the people of Ukraine Ukraine UK is
Europe because you Europe is in the
hearts and in the minds of ukrainians
and soon enough Ukraine will also be in
our
Union honorable
members the anniversary that we Mark
today is a tragic loss of human lives
and suffering and it is all the more
tragic as we know there will be more
pain and more suffering ahead we know
how much is at stake here for those in
Ukraine and also for the rest of
Europe Putin's fantasy and fabricated
war and Ukraine's heroic resistance has
reminded us
here that our freedoms and our democracy
are worth fighting for it so today we
pay tribute to those who are fighting
and we pay tribute to those who paid the
ultimate sacrifice in fighting for
something Slava
Ukraine